any hope of finding someone in this
Devastation has been lost Emergency
Services in Saint Helia are now not
searching for and rescuing survivors but
recovering their bodies
it was so scary to see like Kika was
packing delivery orders when evacuated
families and vulnerable people from
neighboring Apartments began to arrive
at the Town Hall she tried her best to
comfort them we sat inside so I don't
need to go to the bathroom and
everything of course they just left the
beds in a hurry so we're just giving
coffees then some of them were leaving
some of them were getting in sitting
again just trying to get themselves
together again
in This Island Town everyone feels
impacted by this tragedy this Sunday
service reflected a community in
mourning people are feeling traumatized
it's a it's a small community it sounds
like a cliche but it is a small
community everybody knows one another
and although names haven't been released
yet everybody will know someone who has
been involved in is either uh people who
have died or or families that that are
relatives of them
people are also wanting answers of how a
block of flats could be reduced to
Rubble
officials are continuing to be pressed
on how this could happen locals say just
days before they had alerted the
relevant authorities because some of
them could smell gas just hours before
the explosion they're building they've
been deemed safe this is an unthinkable
accident and an investigation has begun
and we will have to wait for the
findings that professional and
independent oversight will provide but
in the meantime we've got to focus on
making the buildings safe and recovering
the people that are within it
a gas leak is one possible cause but
it's too early to say
you look at the pictures and it looks
likely likely that that is the case but
of course as you often hear the Police
Service say you know we keep all our
options open that seems likely but we do
not know is the simple answer
the Island's gas supplier and fire
service are already aiding the police
investigation answers they say won't
take days but weeks instead
Jersey